what we're going to do in this video is
start trying to divide by two digit
numbers and as we'll see this is a super
important skill that a lot of the rest
of mathematics will build off of but
it's also interesting because it's a bit
of an art so let's just start by trying
to compute what 186 divided by 31 is and
of course we could also write this as
186 divided by 31 pause the video and
see if you can figure it out
alright now let's work through this
together I assume you've given it a go
at it so I don't have my thirty-one
times tables memorized so I can't just
immediately tell you the answer but my
brain tries to approximate these numbers
so that my times tables knowledge does
come in handy for example 31 is close to
30 this is why I'm saying it's a bit of
an art but I'm saying hey look this is
pretty close to 30 and if I think about
multiples of 30 well those are just the
multiples of 3 with an extra zero or the
multiples of 3 times 10 so the multiples
of 30 or 30-60-90 instead of 3 times 4
is 12 30 times 4 is 120 150 instead of
15 180 instead of 18 for 30 times 6 and
gee this looks pretty close to 180 so
this looks close to 30 times 6 and if
this is close to 30 well maybe maybe
this is maybe this is going to be 6
right over here and I'm going to put a
question mark because then the natural
thing to do is it to actually try it out
figure out what is 6 times 31 I'll put
the question mark here again is this
equal to 6 well the art part is you've
made a good or we've made a good guess
here now let's try to verify that maybe
it is 6 maybe it isn't so let's multiply
6 or let's multiply 31 times 6
31 times 6 1 times 6 is 6 and then 3
times 6 which is really 30 times 6 is
going to be 180 right over here so this
is 186 so it all works
out 186 divided by 31 is indeed six we
can get rid of this question mark here
let's do another example so let me
delete let me delete that as well let's
say we want to figure out what 336
divided by 48 is equal to so pause this
video and see if you can figure it out
so the way I would think about it this
thing right over here is close to 50
close to 50 and this thing well if you
think about the multiples of 50 you have
things like 300 which would be 50 times
6 and then you have 350 which would be
50 times 7 because 5 times 7 is 35 and
so let's think about this and actually
write those these things down if I were
to say 50 times 6 that's the same thing
as well that's going to be 5 times 6
times 10 which is 300 if I say 50 times
7 that's going to be 350 5 times 7 is 35
and you're multiplying that by 10 and
this number is some place in between 300
and 350 so my candidates for what this
is going to be well I'm saying hey maybe
since 6 maybe this is 7 and what I would
do is I would try out each of them so
let's try out 48 times 6 so let's try
that this first candidate out 48 times 6
so 8 times 6 is going to be 48 4 times 6
is 24 plus 4 is 288 so that actually
seems a good bit lower than this it
actually seems almost exactly 48 lower
so I could probably I'm feeling pretty
confident that I can squeeze another 48
into this so I'm going to get instead of
squeezing 4 instead of being able to
divide 6 48 into this I'm feeling pretty
good that maybe 7 is the answer but let
me try it out so this so 6 is not
going to be my answer I tried it out let
me try 48 times 748 times 7 8 times 7 is
56 4 times 7 is 28 plus 3 336 that's
exactly right
so there you have it with a little bit
of trial and error but it was an
informed trial and error we got 336
divided by 48 is equal to 7 this is what
I meant but there's it's a bit of an art